walk him to this video playing the
national must have shimmy here show me
from the UK Simon Ansel all right let's
go for H from because g6 is such a bad
move you can immediately shout with h4
yeah probably it's not it's not so
terrible hmm the question is how to plan
to play maybe I can I should try to open
up the position get into kind of
Scandinavian don't want to spend ages
here to try to refute that probably it's
not not that possible anyway to really
refute it in a sense that like as a
substantial advantage okay so we have a
Scandinavian width on with each form
there maybe take stakes he can exchange
on the edge farm huh that is interesting
because Knight f6 could be answered with
h6
okay maybe let's go for 95 or let's keep
this as a possible option
okay um is it possible maybe to play
Knight e5 here and then sacrifice on f3
that looks looks a bit ridiculous butter
maybe maybe it's so this is actually
possible check no c 6-r point if it
takes g4 I 10 B 5 this should be you
should be fine the thing is his King
relaxer defenders aha curious move I go
to be 6
1 95 95 every day I can just go Quinn d8
but there i'm also looking at at the g
one square so if i have a second on a
three years this is interesting wait i
actually have a very good good good
person here yeah this one this is this
is interesting it takes with the night
crew g1 is winning and if it takes with
the pawn i have worked the aid at least
through the eight maybe I have something
but I'm group tha I can donate deform
but it's very good for black isn't it
our queen a6 yeah this is this is cute I
can just take it up like Renee six check
to win to win the bishop which leaves me
with a couple of extra extra pawns
yeah so chance move
Oh
there's something something better
night at five is no no Kim or not I can
just take him this is better so let's do
a count yet I mean two pawns up right
you have two points and just got this
shaky king okay I must always get rid of
the Queen's then queen a five after sea
fog ago queena five check exchange
Queens and try to get to a technical
position on Bishop g5 I have 94
yeah that's just a good tackle square
here also
to prevent it general look each one now
again go to g7 but I have kinky things
which is convenient just kind of just
covering here
it takes a half Knight f6 35 I can't use
them yeah this is another possibility
but now the dipole is so very quick
yeah I get get b5 and some the applied
resins fall soon yeah I'm the Sun
somehow blew up into into whites faces
this edge fun stuff but that's probably
not not so bad right here this is
probably about equal but here I don't
know here already like you're like my
position I don't I don't really believe
that 92 was a good move it seems to
clutter up your your development somehow
here this this gets tricky I mean check
okay the computer already believes this
this is almost losing it should be five
because of what happened in the game I
guess yeah 26 is much better than taking
because because of this the influence of
the Queen here and in this direction I
went here I know Bishop f3 is good young
it is simply a good me check and bishops
III winning yeah I didn't see that
before and of course but it was somehow
on we worked out nicely the check check
leads to his to disaster probably now
black can play all kinds of moves but
this this looks good securing the night
and this King feet will just get just
get mated so you have to check here who
create and then it's exactly how it
happened is your game play all the the
comp moose it's not it's not difficult i
mean but sometimes it's it's really
working out check yeah
and this is just a very easily winning
end game yeah hy some probably a not
great for white but shouldn't be a
disaster all this in combination with 92
needs to it a bit of a tricky position I
believe alright thanks for watching